hey guys Greg here John we're gonna be
doing a review of the movie
get out directed and written by Jordan
Peele
Jordan banana peel right now there's
kids right outside this window their
lives playing music and talk and loud so
if you hear them
I'm not going to silence them today and
those are cats those are [ __ ] cats
I'm not going to sign us a kid today
because I'm moving out of this apartment
within the next week so I'm like
whatever let them make some noise last
time I don't want something be quiet one
more time what [ __ ] ate them I can't
wait to move another cute kids their
cuteness anyway the movie get out this
movies about a man black man named Chris
who's dating a Caucasian girl named Rose
they're eliminating for a few months now
he's either in love he's going to go
visit his girlfriend's parents on their
family estate where things suspiciously
started going weird because the family
and people who come to visit take an
awkward interest in black people now
this film though you know I don't want
to review too much of the film because I
don't want to give anything away cuz
it's such a fun thrill ride just to kick
off the reel I'll tell you this one was
excellent yes it was horrific move it's
massively crap that it's wonderfully
written beautifully directed the music
is great then the acting is really
really cop not yet Foreman PSA's from
Emerald lying around yeah it's one of
those horror films that it takes its
time but it also moves along pretty fast
and I really like the tone and the style
of this overall so oh yeah I mean it's
very natural and it's a character piece
and it's a mood piece you know more than
anything it's not necessarily like crazy
plot but there is just enough of that to
really a get super intriguing but also
very personal and especially for like a
first writing directing you know outing
for Jordan Peele I mean it's super
impressive
super impressive and knowing that Jordan
Peele did it if you watch any of key and
Peele you'll see that a lot of their
sketches there's honor inspired a lot of
them are horror genre inspired so I was
excited knowing that he's
psychological horror film and if you're
gonna call it some a psychological
horror film that's the best way to
describe it in my opinion
yeah very psychological this whole
experience it's weird it's sometimes
trippy but it also feels like real when
normal at the same time you know yeah I
mean they're there a lot of like
interesting visual metaphors and stuff
and interesting ways of shooting things
they bring up even if they get a little
out there they all seem to really match
and really communicate you know the
feeling of the movie and the feeling of
the turns in the story because this is a
really sort of unsettling movie and in a
quiet kind of way Oh totally the bills
greatest strengths are in its characters
I've you Daniel Kuya Scalia son like
that he's in saqqara plays emily Blunt's
partner and he is also in the sexy his
second episode of black mirror yeah he's
wonderful in this I think the guy's
British in real life I believe he does
some great American accent and he's a
really natural actor he's this guy who
we learned early on has a rather
traumatized past he lost his mother to a
hit and run when he was about 11 years
old he's addicted to cigarettes
it's funny because it's um kind of is
like a horror movie of Meet the Parents
gonna meet the parents Ben Stiller's
character is going to go meet his family
her family hood the family's all
suspicious and bent and Ben Stiller it
likes to smoke but you know he doesn't
want the family in BO random when he
smokes he doesn't want them to know he
smokes and it kind of plays on that
element a little bit then the other
character we meet his Rose played by
Allison Williams true we know from girls
both of the duo an amazing job Allison
Williams I fell in love with her and the
other thing like her character and girls
can tend to piss me off I mean yeah
she's beautiful but she can kind of
irritating me not because of her acting
it's the way her character is and her
character here a greatly fell in love
with her I fell in love with Daniel and
the two of them together really bought
them as this couple which is the heart
of this film which is the strength of
this film is you really love these two
as a couple you do you want it to work
out you want to work out we can to be
some kind of success you really feel
that she has his back on everything that
she also sees how weird people are
treating you know Chris and treat black
people overall like he's not alone on
this you because it does plan that
element of racism a lot and it plays on
an element of a black guy being
predominantly white community as well
well yeah I mean this to me played like
a racial body horror movie when I'm
curious as to you know what some of the
critics in the black community would
have to say because it's a it is sort of
a different experience ya know to have
is a focal detail in a horror movie cuz
you know a lot of the situations come in
the gray area of you how her family is
perceiving him and how their friends are
all perceiving him and and he is sort of
the most normal guy in the movie while
everyone else is you know all shades of
racially strange yeah exactly because
some of these guys don't seem like
they're exactly racist like they hate
black people they just seem to take a
weird curiosity into black people yeah
we really noticed that a guy's black and
you know yeah it becomes unnatural in
the opposite direction where it's like
you become some sort of novelty or like
a pet yeah we're like and I think it
plays with a lot of those different
dynamics I mean there's a great you know
strange little dynamic just between
Chris and the the - you know help
members who who work for this girl's
family and they go home for these other
black characters who you know the dad of
the family Bradley Whitford Dean called
Boone Holden servants yeah I'm going to
use that word here Georgina and Walter
Georgie and slay by Betty Gabriel
Walter's played by Marcus Henderson it
sets it up in a way where you think okay
when Chris gets there Chris feels like
okay the people who can probably bond
without the two black people that are
working here but they seem really off as
well it's like an uncomfortable Pleasant
tree in their personality it's like a
fake altered kind of greetings they have
a weird Stepford thing in it and again
like every situation this movie walks
into almost makes you wonder about the
circumstances and about what everyone's
really feeling about all this yeah but
everyone's a very fleshed out character
in Allison Williams is a great like
brings a lot of great personality to it
where she is a lovable girlfriend and
she's more than just the lovable
girlfriend she's she's multi-layered in
the parents to Bradley Whitford does a
great job in this role yeah you
instantly buy him as a neurosurgeon dad
who likes to be cool and relatable and
then Catherine Keener seems more like
the humble more calm one who could see
her husband's weirdness but they have a
great chemistry as a husband and wife
together the whole family like really
does Neil
like a family and Caleb Landry Jones the
other character who I forgot he was even
in then asked her brother and he and
that was a nice spin on us too but every
time you think a cliche element is
coming they haven't have a good twist on
it yeah you know like you hear about
other son he's studying medicine then he
shows up and he they don't show him the
treasure don't give it away but he's
totally different than what your first
thinking when you hear about like I'm
thinking oh this is going to be like the
really good behaving white son yeah has
a suit hey mom hey David he's nothing
like that and it's done in a way that
was very different and worked very well
for this specific film as well there's a
whole lot inside of this guy overall
from from the the subtext and the
character stuff all the way down to the
visual because it's shot really well
totally it has a very distinct very
assured visual the aisle very shirred
pace like they're only a couple times
where it ever feels choppy at all and
one thing that we learn early on is a
Katharine Tina's character she's a
psychiatrist who specializes in hypnosis
and the hypnosis sequences are great
they're wonderfully active his specific
performance and his first hypnosis scene
that was power is incredible yeah you're
just like like watching this guy
struggle with having a face a dark
reality in his past which was like
beautiful you could feel so much history
this guy tree like he created a full
task in this performance you know like
it was it was absolutely brilliant away
it was all active those hypnosis scenes
too were impressive because the way they
slip into the movie the first one I
didn't even realize what was happening
until halfway through the scene where I
was like ah you know you pick it up
there's some excellent subtlety in this
movie about like you said just boldface
performances yeah and there's like
several kind of horror blends you get
sick mind trippy hypnosis sequences you
get like one or two jump scares yeah
it's not really like full-blown with
jump scares it's more just a creepy
eerie film where you're wondering like
what the [ __ ] is going on and what's
going on with the black people in this
community yeah I mean this bill is a
really really cool metaphor you know for
I guess feeling like an alien you know
in the way also you know white people
get weird and
try to 8:00 you know black culture and
yeah that sort of take it as their own
like there's a lot this discusses like I
know that it's going to be kind of
difficult to discuss race when it comes
to this movie because it is an integral
part but it's not like it's going to
sour your ass your manages to not do it
in some pre she sort of way yeah I was
really impressed by like it really made
me feel like oh man this must be like
what this is a metaphor must really
truly be an awkward living experiment oh
yeah totally and I gotta say Betty
Gabriel as Georgina what a fantastic job
she'd oh dude she didn't cry creepy
eerie at times you kind of like care for
her you want to like Chris help her out
helps figure out what hang on with this
girl it Walter Marcus Henderson's
character another really effectively
eerie dude I love the way the mystery is
done here because it really is one of
those great mystery movies where you're
like I want to know what is going on
yeah like it keeps reeling you in makes
you ask questions it's done in a way
where when everything is being revealed
it's just not what you'd expect and yet
when the reveal finally there and you
look at all the former events you're
like ah yeah oh I make sense I wake all
play
I knew something weird was going on here
but I did not expect yeah yeah you know
I saw the signs of boy what did I get in
there there's some cool great twists and
turns and then the unraveling of all the
other characters okay is amazingly done
you know learning foods really evil
who's really this and that this movie
has a great balance and it has a really
tight plot like everywhere the movie
goes from one place math is really
sensible like I thought structured
incredibly well enough I mean like it
takes its time because it's so much
development happening within the
characters and the mystery yet it was it
such a great steady pace that you're
never bored
you're just not voice it's a cool film
it's yeah it's cool it's a cool but no
it's a Hulett it's in an in-kind art
house in Indy but it's also screwing and
in growth yeah just everything pretty
much everything is top-notch and there's
a character in there play by little ray
Howry forgot the character's name plays
he plays Chris's best friend and like
when Chris and is girlfriend go on this
trip
friend is watching their dog and he's
that character who like he believes
anything that sounds suspicious like his
mind can jump the crazy conclusion he
provides a lot of the humor for this
film and a lot of critics I understand
like this film that's funny
I wouldn't call it a comedy by any means
no I was right about that it's not a
comedy by any means there's definitely
humor sprinkled in it throughout katha
because it really comes alive through
the characters performances and
especially this guy little raised his
performance Louella alright no there's
harmonies already yeah larell Rama Rao
my bad I thought that little Rick oh
yeah I mean he is rapper but he's the
most uh like outwardly humorous
character but even he is like you know
the common sense right or have this
movie in a great way and the thing is
like I think everybody will have a
different experience I laughed a lot
during this movie even though I still
wouldn't say like it's really funny but
if those ironic moments you know where
you know something else is going on and
the character says something kind of
humorously in contrast like there's a
lot of subtle humor in here - yeah every
character no one's a plot device in this
film no everyone's very much flushed out
and serves a great purpose to the
overall film and the way just keeps
unraveling it's a very captivating film
it's [ __ ] tighter than any like it's
brilliant I thought it was I was like
this lives up to everything my only
issue like the trailer I thought was
amazing but I will say the trailer does
it doesn't necessarily spoil everything
but when like a scene is happening and
then like let's say when someone dies in
the scene you're able to I was able to
see it coming because I'm like oh this
looks familiar from the trailer when
this one guy got okay yeah that's what
and a lot of times I'm like a certain Oh
shock moment happens I'm like oh well
the trailer condition show me a little
image of that which made me go oh that
must be worth it this guy updaters were
to happen I thought about that in the
moment where the groundskeepers like
running at him like if I had seen that
moment cold and not like yeah every time
I saw that trailer that I think would
have really you know unsettled me in a
different way so yeah you know I
definitely do that but there's still a
lot of wonderful surprises I don't think
you'll see the reveal coming like when
they explain what's going on I don't
think you'll see that coming it still
makes everything make sense
bottom line wonderfully directed or
wonderfully written wonderfully shot
great music and superb acting I can't
remember the last movie I got done with
like I think I love this movie yeah you
know I think this might be one of my
favorite I mean 2016 was a great year
for horror 2017 or a start us off with
split and now get out and they're both
from bloom house yeah the company John
works for isn't that interesting and we
saw a cure for wellness which was also
great and now get out three great horror
films within the span of a couple months
of 2017 so I can't wait to see what else
is in store for horror this year I can't
wait to see what Jordan Peele doesn't
like I hope he does more horse I don't
know if this is just you know what he
needed for this particular story he
really knows how to set environment mood
like just in the opening credits like
the opening credits are just a shot
through a car window of looking at the
trees of the forest showing like they're
going somewhere very secluded and very
far away from every scene or trees yeah
all time and it but it puts you a nap
that mood like they're gonna be very
much isolated here it does have sort of
an old-timey dread because even that
credit sequence is kind of you know it
has a lot of the credits in it like an
older movie would and like it really
does take its time out settle you in to
the identity of the movie and it's a
movie all about kind of the horrors of
identity and is great sound designers
film too so the sound as I make a lot of
the scenes had that extra punch to it
and the music is so effective there's
like three different songs that are play
within the first 10 minutes of this
movie but it's not only on its quad but
it it but the ways like the way the
transitions are done and the music
choices were yeah this was this isn't
like we all knew this was going to be a
good film and it really delivered yeah
this is I think the most effortlessly
I've seen something wrong I'm like that
looks awesome I'm just going to allow
myself into excited for it I saw it and
it was awesome in ways that I hoped it
could be and in ways that surprised me
so the rating system Times masterpiece
kind of you know it's not going to win
my the [ __ ] Oscar maybes and
hopefully maybe if they own the [ __ ]
consider horror movies a little more
often especially Daniel performance man
like huge performance is not equal
rating got dynamite like that
performance is awesome he is so natural
like he's so fun and if I had to give
one judgement it would probably just be
the way the finale kind of goes down
within the last 20 minutes it's it's a
little bit too much like yeah
I can't give away my prawns with it but
but it's done in a way where it's not
necessarily cliche but it borderline
goat
cliche for me I have to clarify identify
it would ruin the film for it I think
the only complaint I would have is like
there are times in towards the third act
where you know I guess you can complain
that some of the more comedic scenes
some of the more comedic cutaway scenes
to his friends are a little bit more
funny than the rest of the movie and
they kind of stand out a bit but I don't
think there's anything in here looking
oh so that's a real vibe yeah yeah and
that's and that's been the tradition of
certain other horror movies too so I
guess there's nothing in here that I do
that I think just absolutely doesn't
belong or take it away from the story I
can also see maybe again anytime there's
some kind of ending reveal you know you
might lose a couple people I think this
movie's reveal is really cool you take a
leap but where they land I think really
works but you know you might not I mean
2016 was a great year for horror movies
2017 we already got split and we saw a
cure for wellness which was also great
and now get out three great horror films
within the span of a couple months of
2017 so I can't wait to see what else is
in the store for horror this year all
right guys well if you're new to the
channel subscribe to the reel rejects he
is a social media manager of bloom house
and the real rejects follow him on
Twitter and Instagram and reasons to
Jerry my shoutouts going to be dedicated
to Daniel Kazuya Kahlua Kahlua
Daniel Kaluga he was in Johnny English
Reborn and kick-ass - he's the sequel
guy in episode 2 of black mirror oh man
he's the new rock he's number two and
we're not going to wonder if this guy's
black or not like the rock let him know
he's black